- Yo.
Let's go.
Hold on. I'm gonna put
you guys on speaker.
Hold on a second.
- [Interviewer] How do you ensure
a good nights sleep while traveling?
Bring your own pillow?
Travel with exercise equipment?
Request specific rooms
instead of bed time, etc?
- I'm actually super
not particular or fancy
so I ensure a good nights sleep
because I leave it all on the field,
the 18 hours that I'm awake
and so I'm so unconscious by the time
it's time to go to sleep
that I can fall asleep on nails
in an Iraqi prison.
- [Interviewer] What is a feature question
in terms of marketing, currency,
or should you have had any doubt
that their companies ready for the future?
- The question should be do
we have a good understanding
of where the consumer
that we're trying to reach
is spending their time and attention
and do we understand
how to create the words,
sounds, videos, and pictures
that would influence them to
do what we want them to do
on and in those places.
- [Interviewer] How do
you see the concepts
of crushing it applying to
intrapreneurs at a company
as opposed to entrepreneur's
trying their own thing?
- You know intrapreneurs are able to,
if they're in the right corporations,
they'll be able to produce content
that would allow their seniority leaders
to see some of their thoughts
that maybe they wouldn't hear in a meeting
or through the serendipity
of crossing them in a halls
or a business environment
and so they're able to
share their opinions,
thoughts, and ideas in a manner
that would allow people to consume it,
a.k.a a medium post a LinkedIn
post that they would post
has the serendipitous opportunity
or strategic media planned opportunity
for their bosses boss boss to read
and if her idea was phenomenal,
that may lead to an opportunity
within that organization.
- [Interviewer] If there's
a zombie apocalypse,
what would be your weapon of choice?
- My words.
(laughing)
They laughed. That was awesome.
They loved it.
- [Interviewer] How can I separate myself
from my company?
- Do you have contacts if that person
is asking how they can separate themselves
from their company because
they own that company?
- [Interviewer] Yes. This is owner.
- By being disciplined and understanding
that your company isn't you
and you aren't your company.
That's a mindset strategy.
You know, without a healthy
separation of understanding
that it could really lead
to a detrimental mindset.
- [Interviewer] Gary, if
you could have a coffee
and conversation with anyone in the world,
and it can be someone from
the past, alive or dead,
who would it be and what
would you talk about?
- Outside of my two grandfathers,
who I never got to know,
which would easily be the answer,
we would talk just about
the history of our family,
their parents and grandparents.
That would just be interesting to me.
No question, it would be
Randy the Macho Man Savage.
Note, I'm super sad that I wasn't able to
get to a place where I met him
and got to have a conversation.
He was such a great story teller
and like my favorite wrestler
and I think we would have talked about
like early wrestling
history, his baseball career,
and why I think a lot of my content
is inspired by him.
- [Interviewer] As an owner of a plumbing
and heating company with 11 employees,
do you feel that phone book, radio,
and newspaper ads still work for marketing
in my industry?
- What was the first part?
I heard the 11 employees but not the rest.
- [Interviewer] As an owner of a plumbing
and heating company with 11 employees,
do you feel that phone book, radio,
and newspaper ads still work for marketing
in my industry?
- Uh, I think they work.
I think everything works.
I think they're grossly overpriced.
If you spend $1,000 on yellow pages
and you get one customer form it,
it worked but it cost you $1,000.
You know, to me, that same
1,000 gets you four customers
on Facebook even when you suck at it.
So, the answer is no.
By the way it's asked, the answer is yes,
because I'm trying to be nuanced here
and educate people on LinkedIn
and obviously my blog who
is watching right now.
So the answer is sure
but I think it's grossly overpriced
and that same money spent
on Google and Facebook
and influencers and podcasting
would go much further.
- [Interviewer] How do you say no
to different opportunities and focus
on current goals and projects?
- Poorly.
I have big eyes and big ambitions
and I'm very curious
and so I struggle with this.
I've gotten better over time
and that's because I've learned
that it's not in my best interest
and so I wouldn't suppress it completely
because that's what keeps you
creative and entrepreneurial
but I think it's just an
evolution of trying your best
and always remembering what the prize is.
- [Interviewer] What types
of context will exist
in the future that don't exist today
that you're excited about?
- Probably holograms.
You know, I can see that and I'm excited
about being in hologram form
and marketing that way.
And then probably three
things that I've never
even thought of in a million years.
Inventions that don't even exist yet.
I never, ever, ever, ever
thought about self driving cars
until I first heard about it.
I never thought about augmented reality
and how people would see fake characters
in my content until I heard about it.
I never thought about virtual reality
until I heard about it.
I never thought about having a cell phone
when cell phones didn't exist
so, um, things that don't exist.
- [Interviewer] What is the
best way to close a sale?
- By disproportionately over communicating
on the value props that
that persons looking for.
Clear and concise communications in a deck
or verbal form
that are scratching the
needs of that customer.
- [Interviewer] Does God believe in you?
- What's that?
- Sure.
- [Interviewer] What's the
best wine you've ever had?
- 1947 Cheval
C h e v a l
Blanc
B l a n c.
- [Interviewer] Perfect.
How would you approach
changing how leadership
occurs in today's education system?
- Oh my God. I mean ...
I mean, this is how I'm gonna answer this.
- [Interviewer] What would you change?
- What's that?
- [Interviewer] What would
you change about today's
education system if you could?
- Everything. Like it's, uh,
I don't even want to disrespect,
this is how I want you to answer it.
I don't even want to
disrespect you, x, y, z,
you know, who asked this question
by giving a half assed answer
meaning it's so binarily broken to me
that I would literally need to
make a 45 minute documentary
to answer that question.
There's no 5 to 7 to 15 sentences
that could even begin to
allow me to tackle it.
It's broken at its core.
- [Interviewer] Subway or McDonald's?
- McDonald's.
- [Interviewer] Do you
ever turn off social media?
Do you ever take a break?
- Yeah. When I go on vacation.
On some weekends during Jet games.
Tons of time.
- [Interviewer] How did you
get your start in investing?
What tools or platforms did you use
and how did you broaden
your understanding of the stock market?
- I don't know anything
about the stock market.
So let me start there.
And when it came to investing,
I became friendly with
some of the early employees
of Twitter, which then
allowed me to buy his shares
and that's how it started.
It was just personal relationships
that led to an opportunity
to acquire some equity
and then from there,
once I was a Twitter stockholder
and Twitter exploded that year,
other companies started coming to me
and I learned on the fly of what it meant
to buy from employees,
what it meant to invest in a
series A or B or a seed round.
It was a learning by, you
know, baptized by fire,
or whatever it was.
- [Interviewer] Cool. So
our Pete's from India,
said after he got his
MBA, he went to a job.
But then he left that job in 7 months
because he wasn't learning anything
and the growth was slow.
And now, he can't find a new job
because he didn't stay
at that job for one year.
And he's been thinking about going,
taking over his fathers business
but the business has been bad
and now he's afraid, "Should I do that?
And what if it fails and I
won't be able to get a job
after that either because I
haven't completed that trip.
It's like I only lasted 7 months at a job
and I failed at my dad's business."
- There's too many other jobs
that don't give a shit
about those two failures.
So he should go into
his dad's business ASAP
and there will be hundreds of people
that are willing to hire him
with those two strikes on his resume.
My intuition is that he didn't try
to go to enough places.
I don't think every job in the world
viewed him not working
somewhere for a year
as a scarlet letter.
- [Interviewer] How do
you define kindness?
- Uh, that's a great question.
Somebody who brings warmth
and value to somebody with
no expectation in return.
- [Interviewer] What do
you recommend for someone
who is almost 24 and has a
business and marketing degree
but has no clue what they
want to do for their career?
- Do something.
- [Interviewer] What
companies are screaming
out to you currently to invest in?
- I have no idea.
I'm so clueless to businesses right now.
Like Phil Toronto is
filtering that stuff for me
but I mean tons.
I get hundreds of emails a day
but I literally pay them no mind.
I'm totally checked out
of investing right now.
- [Interviewer] What
comes after social media?
- I have no idea.
- [Interviewer] I would really
appreciate any knowledge
of how to start your first business
with a really low credit score
but over five years of experience.
- Get somebody to give you
money that isn't a bank.
Or start selling shit from the beginning
and make profit from the beginning
and be patient.
Raising capital is only
one highly over popular
way to start a business.
- [Interviewer] You
always say you have time.
So what were you doing at 24?
- I was working 15 hours a day
in a liquor store in New Jersey
making $47,000 a year
in the process of building a
huge business for my parents
working seven days a week
doing zero things socially.
- [Interviewer] What's been
the hardest part for you
when it comes to leading people?
- Not a lot, actually.
I love that.
I think I'm a real natural leader
because I have zero expectation of others.
Firing. I would say firing.
- [Interviewer] Which marketing channel
would be the best to consider in 2018
for the B to B vector?
- A combination of Facebook and LinkedIn
and Google Search.
Google Search and Google pre roll,
YouTube pre roll videos based
on Google Search queries.
ETA?
- [Driver] 23 minutes.
- [Interviewer] Where do you
see yourself in 10 years?
- I don't. I don't think
of, I don't do that.
I want to film, I want
this whole thing filmed.
The spitting. The whole thing.
What's up, YouTube?
- [Interviewer] What do
you look for instinctually
when you are researching your clients?
- I don't research my clients.
- [Interviewer] Where do
you go when you feel stuck?
- Within my own head.
- [Interviewer] What's
the one thing you know now
that you didn't when you were younger?
- God, a lot.
I mean, everything.
Like I believe in experience tremendously.
What really stands out?
It's really funny how similar
I am to when I was a kid,
it's just a dance version.
I think everything, man.
I just think everything.
I would just put everything.
It's the right answer.
- [Interviewer] How
would you suggest older,
more well connected experts
and later career individuals,
whether it's LinkedIn and new tools,
who wanted more successful
business opportunities?
- By sharing their wisdom and knowledge
in written or video
form at scale for free,
aka write a lot of things like
what did you learn when you were older
that you didn't know when you
were young kind of pieces.
- [Interviewer] Suppose I
just bought the New York Jets,
what would become of Gainer?
Also, are you happy?
- I would start focusing
on the New York Knicks
and I'm extremely happy.
- [Interviewer] Do you always feel ready
or are you ever nervous?
- I always feel ready.
- [Interviewer] How do I get more clients
for my consulting company?
What small steps can I
take today for the Magma?
- Start producing content
on LinkedIn, Facebook,
and allow the content to be your lead gen
to your business leads.
- [Interviewer] Is it good to help people
even when you know they don't deserve it?
- Yes. You don't help
people based on them.
You help people based on you.
Giving is selfish.
- [Interviewer] What are your
thoughts on having your team
work remote or having them
all in the same office?
- I'm an all in the
same office kind of guy
cause I like the touchy feely
and human interaction.
But I think remote works
if you look in the 37 signals founders,
they love that and others.
I don't think it's a right or wrong.
I think it's a very
personal kind of thing.
- [Interviewer] That's all we got.
- Wow.
Pretty cool.
- [Interviewer] Is Tyler with you?
You're recording this?
- Yeah, Tyler recorded everything.
I'm gonna make a video
just of the whole thing.
- [Interviewer] Awesome.
- People watching this video,
which was your favorite
question and answer?
Thanks for watching.
(soft music)